it was you know it was probably the most
important shift in my career because not
because of it started the notoriety that
I got on the internet it's because
YouTube's selling to Google for 1.7
billion dollars you know I'm there
wasn't a single video on YouTube that
had a million views when I was on there
was no videos that were 20 minutes long
YouTube literally flew me out to like
explain why I was making videos over 10
minutes long and when it sold no
question that singular day was the day
that I realized huh I have some skill
you know what it made me do was look
back and say you know launching an
e-commerce website in 1996 was probably
pretty progressive after all doing email
marketing when nobody was doing it was
probably right and buying those Google
AdWords the day Google AdWords came out
that was probably smarter than I thought
it was no question the tipping point
where I was like hey I have something
else going on here other than I'm a good
wine merchant this is more macro and
obviously reading the articles of that
Google sale purchase it there were a
couple that referenced and it was the
first time I'd ever seen it this term
angel investor because I think a lot of
people what they don't know you know I
think people kind of the people that
know my story they don't realize how
insular I was I was I wasn't in Silicon
Valley I was in New Jersey I was in a
cocoon of the wine business
I was super undereducated so I didn't
even really understand the world to be
very frank like I didn't you know for
example even a year later when I
invested in Facebook
had I known of even the most basic
concept of carrying people's money and
making a 20% on the back end I would
have I don't even want to know what I
would have happened because I basically
bet my life that Facebook was gonna win
and to just think about even getting
five million dollars of the liquor
industry's rich guys and gals money and
having another million on the backend I
mean
you know just to give you context if
that would have translated into a
hundred eighty million dollars I mean it
was it was it's really fun for me to
think about the brilliance of the things
that I think I've done and the insanity
and basicness and I think that there's a
level of and I'm still that guy right
now there's a deep commitment an
obsession to the end consumer and almost
nothing else and what that means is I've
got to go through my own patterns to get
educated and so yeah I was a I was I saw
YouTube it was three months old nothing
was going on there was maybe some random
article I'm like slash dot you know
about it back in the day nerd stuff and
I was like this is this is it this thing
is it and then right behind that I
decided I would be an angel investor and
if I felt that feeling of why I did e
Tom email Google AdWords and YouTube if
I had that feeling really I would
compare it like the only comp that I've
seen that I've consumed is the way Clive
Davis in his documentary talked about
you know Mariah Carey or Celine Dion I
genuinely believe I trade on intuition
and ear and understanding of what you're
gonna do before you do it the way I'm
gonna trade voice going forward for the
next decade and that's that's how it
happened and so I started the wine show
and it changed the course of my career
yep recently went back and watched
episode 1 just for its pure authenticity
and broadness of what it's like to get
started pioneering something new and
then they come to see you do a thousand
of those shows later yeah which is a
level of commitment yeah I mean jumping
to number three
I mean it's staggering to me that people
don't understand the variable that hard
work is you know it's it's it's
stunningly funny to me that people don't
want to acknowledge it people love to
talk about working smart people love it
and that's fine and I think that's
exactly right but you don't know a
single person that has ever become
successful without putting in an
obnoxious amount of work it doesn't
exist
you know people that have wealth that
were handed it but you know nobody who's
earned it without putting in the work
and and I think you know and the reason
I like it so much even at the face of
push back in today's very live your life
work-life balance environment and I love
it I love it I'm thrilled for that you
need to be self-aware I love it because
it feels the most controllable it feels
a hell of a lot more exciting to me give
advice and say if you're not happy work
three more hours a day than it is go get
smarter February 21st 2006 watching
what's happening with entrepreneurship
right now is very exciting and
concerning all at the same time you know
I'm 42 years old I was an immigrant from
the Soviet Union education was the way
out and I was a DNF student and so
basically what that meant if you grew up
in the 80s and early 90s was every
parent and teacher thought I was gonna
be a loser because it was a binary game
of if you don't go to a great school
you can't win in life it was just you
know for everybody over 40 in here you
understand that it was binary there was
no conversation of entrepreneur I mean
the first time you know entrepreneur was
an extremely new term like even I called
myself a business man not an
entrepreneur entrepreneur meant you were
a loser
like like you had a like a card that
said you were Noir and meant that you
like lived on a beach and had an idea
like it was so terrible and now
everybody's trying to be one and I think
we're over correcting in the same way
that entrepreneurs tried to be good
students and that was a bad idea you've
got a lot of people that should work at
Blackrock and are actually trying to be
entrepreneurs and they will fail because
they're incredible number three seven
nine twenty sevens being a number one is
a totally different DNA trait it means
you love getting punched in the mouth it
means you don't care about what other
people think it means so many things
that we don't talk about and I think a
lot of people will go into very bad
mental places in their mid first of all
if you look at the current state of a 22
year old entrepreneur the scariest part
is if they are over educated they're
going in a system that they've never had
any real adversity the game is so big
diff you come from the right family you
feel no feelings of pushback and then
you go into the wild and you've got a
business and the market the market
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
grandfather and and I'm watching it
every day and it's not fun it's not fun
for a 24-year old 11 months in realizing
that they're soft and not as smart as
they thought they were and their idea of
building the uber for laundromats and
bad idea I've been chasing attention my
whole life this isn't new this is an
email and Google this is I used to do
that I would literally try to figure out
physically with your eyes as a driver
like if you were looking at that tree or
that tree or that post and then I
thought oh my god that's what he did a
baseball card shows at 11:00 that's why
I didn't set up my table for the first
four hours while everybody else did and
would walk the floor and watch what
people reacting to so that I'd go back
and set up my table oh [ __ ] that's why I
dominated in my dad's liquor store
because when I was 14 and stood behind
the register
I would watch people walk into the store
and like how they would navigate oh [ __ ]
that's why my websites did so well
because I was doing UI and UX before I
realize what UI and UX was and it all
came back and probably in the last four
or five years I finally articulated
which is like [ __ ] it's all empathy this
is all empathy I'm a good leader I have
a good community I'm a great with
consumers because I deploy empathy at
scale it is always about them never
about me you want to you want me to save
you a lot of time
Blackrock you know why you can't get
people interested in wealth because it's
about you not them you're trying to
figure out how to make it valuable for
you to get them interested in it in
what's in it for you
the end you haven't reversed engineered
what they give a [ __ ] about and then all
those people in that video
that's cute in front of a camera but
that's not the truth of how they're
going to navigate their lives actually
our videos eventually to whine and then
to say I mean and I love this evolution
from from Gary Vaynerchuk
to Bainer to just a Gary Vee yeah just
like where'd you get your hassle
I think work you know I'm again I'm not
a great student but it seems to me at
least in the ethos that a lot of people
agree that work ethic is taught and so
that's very easy my parents I mean it's
such a big deal
like it's such a big deal my day I mean
I don't even see my dad my dad and I
slept in the same roof every day of my
life for the first 18 years of my life
every day we just didn't we took one
family vacation my dad never traveled
once and I never saw him until I was 14
years old he left before I woke up he
got home after I fell asleep and he was
a merchant right he left at seven he got
home at 11 p.m. that was his life and he
worked every day my parents are from the
Soviet Union so even though they grew up
in the 80s and 90s which is still more
common than today but they lived that
classic 1947 separate life right
like completely set like two separate
entities my mom raised the three of us
we never had it wasn't you know my mom
did everything like I don't even know
how to do laundry like to this day like
she did absolutely everything she worked
from the moment she woke up to the end
of night and so like my parents I wish
no but you know I think I think I think
work ethic is bet my hustle comes from
my parents it's very clear they I mean
you know it's funny me my mom and dad
when it's just the three of us not my
sister and brother which happens rarely
but suck if we are somewhere within the
first hour we'll start making fun of
each other in such a loving way which is
like [ __ ] we're just a bunch of working
dogs you know like we just work like you
know and then I'm competitive and and
with my dad and him with me and so he
worked so much so that I think you know
I have the luxury of the internet and
travel to Al
my dad right like which has been like a
really funny thing with me and him in
the last five years which is like him
conceding that I work harder it's
probably the most devastating thing
that's ever happened to him and easily
the most gratifying thing that's ever
happened to me so my parents okay so I
think by now we have a good picture
yep hard copy books yeah you're also an
online social media guru I'd love to
know your view on like what's the what's
where do you see the purpose of print
today in book form and then just a
couple the key themes that you think are
most important from your your series of
introduce I think that and this could be
a good takeaway as I was thinking about
your business and I think about you know
financial services as a whole and just
everything to be very frank my what I
what do I see in books I think it's a
lack of friction to somebody who wants
to read a book meaning my information
needs to be empathetic to the way people
consume so if there's enough people that
want to read a book and hardcopy I don't
have an ideological point of view on
technology or how one should consume I
could give a [ __ ] if you want to listen
to it on Kindle or audiobook or read a
hard copy or you know to me the greatest
job for all of us is to create no
friction to the way that somebody wants
it and so the place of a book in 2018 is
a lot of people read books and so I
don't have a problem you know producing
my content in that form I think key
themes are self-awareness
patience lack of ideological point of
view on what's happening here I have no
idea I think I I think my little part in
it is I want to bring awareness to it
strength and then maybe that means
something I sure know that it wasn't
alpha-male to talk about empathy and
gratitude and self-awareness and so if
there's
a bunch of people who think I'm cool
that are 17 year olds that now think
that's cool and put more effort into
that that would be good over putting
cash to your ear or champagne bottles or
going like jumping over the fence at a
private playing place to take a photo
like you're going on a private plane for
your Instagram or all the other
horseshit that people think is cool I
don't know how you teach it but I
definitely know it needs to be talked
about so you clearly have the over
because bringing awareness to it you
want me to feed it alright so more about
what you see typed in in the space
whatever industry it is that you think
are the next successful products to come
on right you've had a good nose sticking
out some stuff in the past like what do
you think is next I have not a for a
little while now in early-stage because
the thing of the supply and demand curve
of entrepreneurs got broken and now I'm
guessing versus betting on proper
opportunities
I am absolutely gonna jump back in when
the apps that are built on top of Google
home and Amazon Alexa happen I believe
the next Spotify snapchat Instagram ways
venmo
wish will be built on top of Alexa and
Google I think everybody here will
overly engage with apps built on top of
voice devices and I view the Alexa and
the Google home and the Apple pod the
same way I view the iPhone and the
Android device I think the stakes are
gonna be very high in voice I think a
lot of people are gonna be crushed
including things that like I'm
fascinated that I think Google search in
a visual form is in deep [ __ ] which is
wild right because that this is what's
so fun about getting older or you get to
see things go the whole loop so for me
to be able to live through Google search
destroying things and then becoming the
Yellow Pages itself because a voice is
going to be an
unbelievable thing to watch from
beginning to end but that is happening I
promise all of you in the next 12 to 15
years you'll be stunned by how much your
search is done based on you just talking
in your room not by you grabbing your
phone and doing it because it's just
faster the reason you all text now is it
was faster than a phone call voice will
be faster than texting thus you will
always choose speed you will always
choose speed over everything when I
started you know it's early in over when
I started seeing who was taking ubers a
kay back to wealth people that couldn't
afford it it wasn't me judging people's
you know the the great thing that this
room will struggle with on the black
rock and financial side is people want
to be people want you want them to be
financially fit and smarter about wealth
without understanding what people
actually value people talk because of
social pressure around valuing money
most actually don't so lets you want to
really you want to break through insight
that's one because if you actually
accept that truth you will start
navigating in a very different way
because it's not about your
self-interest and your ideology it's
about the reality of the consumer and
then you can start creating services
around that the ability to do anything I
want at all times that you know so for
me that doesn't take that much money
that takes you have to understand how to
run your own personal PNL I know plenty
people make nine million dollars a year
who have golden handcuffs right because
they've created too much costs to
maintain their lifestyle so for me I got
lucky because I'm addicted to the game
not to the trophy and I understood that
after I dropped the Yankees and the
Rangers after they won their
championships but I'm still feverish
about the Jets and the Knicks I'm in it
for the chase which is geez if you can
get into that you're set because it
really changes it but that's how I
define it I define it as the power to be
able to do whatever I want people like
you're so transparent you're so
authentic I'm like sure because I'm not
worried about the rain
Asians of anything I say well I mean if
you weren't scared of anything you would
tell the truth all the time too
you know I really think I can I want to
but most of all it's fun to try right
like I love that I sold a significant
piece of vaynermedia which everybody
here my financial advisors would have
told me it was stupid and they would
have been right I sold it when I was
doing 14 million it's gonna do 140
million this year and I knew that was
gonna happen I did it because I sold a
piece to Steven Ross the owner of the
Miami Dolphins and over the last six
years I've integrated myself into the
NFL family in a way that's going to
matter because guess what it's an old
boys club and in 22 years when I have
the wealth to get in they're gonna have
to say yes and they say no a lot so you
have to know what you're playing for so
you know we were talking about this and
if people really are following me on
social I'm very much trying to figure
out my team because I I realize you know
right now I'm coming here every three
months this would be music Tareq's here
I'm starting to realize this is gonna
end up being and every six week thing
and you know I'm a die-hard fan I will
tell you the one thing I envy
tremendously so here's what I don't love
about the Premier League it's about
money like there was some reason I don't
like baseball is I don't like that
people buy championships here and that
in itself eliminates a lot of the merit
and excitement and I'm aware that once
in a blue moon a team will come along
and do what happened a couple years ago
but for the most part this is a money
game and so I hate that but what I do
love is that you actually give a [ __ ]
about your team's here like in a way
that is super different than what is
going on in the US like there isn't
diehard fans it's you know this is its
real religion here so it's awesome so I
want to pick a team Taunton is like on
the top of my list the Spurs have my
attention because they haven't won in so
long
so honey ham is super at the top because
of the lack of the championship in the
last 40 years but I'm really thinking
about going for the ultimate climb which
is what if I go to the third division
and see it all the way through so that's
kind of where my head's at right now to
me if you are not relevant as a human or
a business or organization on Facebook
and Google and Instagram and LinkedIn
and YouTube you actually don't exist and
so I think it's the current state of the
internet the way I think voice will be
the next current state of the internet
until we potentially move to blockchain
which will then change this whole game
so I mean it you know it's insane to me
that if you told me hey Garrity do you
want to be on a top ten podcast or do
you want a video to show up on the
number one Instagram account or do you
want to be on the front page of the New
York Times it's like a laughable choice
of the two and so I think it's the
current state of attention I think it
has all the leverage I think it I find
it funny that people in business think
Facebook is a nuanced or can't change
their business yet the CEO has to sit in
front of Congress because the American
institution think it's it's powerful
enough to overthrow the [ __ ]
government you know I I laugh when I'm
here I mean why do you think bruh where
do you think brexit comes from like what
do you think nationalism is being born
from this is it this is the television
and radio of our society the internet
has won there is no debate and and
everybody in this room is grossly under
estimating its power this what we're
doing right now physically is secondary
and the sooner you understand that the
more likely you'll be successful in
whatever your ambitions are whether
there's sell sneakers or to raise money
for the PTA or become the mayor of your
town this right here the physical [ __ ]
it's secondary you may not like it it
doesn't matter what you think
this is where our lives are playing out
and so I think I think under estimating
the power of Facebook and Twitter and
YouTube and podcasting and just the
content of the Internet is that your own
peril perspectives on financial services
things that are not working on in
general there's an audacity that I think
is an enormous vulnerability I think not
unique to financial services anybody in
the world that cares about the financial
health of their business in an every 90
day window is completely [ __ ] and so
my biggest concern for financial
services is most of them play in a Wall
Street environment and they do nothing
but short-term behavior which is defense
in the face of the biggest change in our
society it is it is laughable that venmo
was not created by a financial service
it is laughable for financial services
to be as naive as they are about
blockchain and what that actually means
it's gonna eliminate all your margins I
mean you know look what's what's not
working is not unique to financial
services anybody that is in a lead
position financially in the world today
has their resources tied up in something
that has lost its leverage and so that's
a problem and here's what I think is
funny why are we so entitled to have the
world at a standstill during our lives
meaning I want you to level up what I'm
actually talking about which is why do
we get to have peace and why do we have
to get continuity financially or
economically like why are we not
supposed to be a generation that goes
through a Great Depression why why why
why you know like you know I just in
America always done like I'm like why
can't we be the generation that watches
our empire falling I mean anybody that
doesn't understand the
China's gonna win is just naive this
place used to be number one then America
became number one and the same reason
this place lost its leadership is the
same reason America's gonna lose its
number one it's called entitlement
it's called too much prosperity which
then creates a generation that doesn't
know how to fight for it and so that's
more on a country basis I think this is
a macro thing lifted above all that and
so you know look I you know you make you
when you are friends
when you when you make money by being in
the middle and the internet and
blockchain come along and they're the
actual middle you're in trouble
so you need to figure out what the hell
you're actually doing and providing
value and the fact that you amassed a
moat that gave you an advantage too and
that became your middle that's a bad
business when that doesn't bring any
value anymore so let me tell you what I
do think is working and I do think
Blackrock has done this incredibly well
and I'm sure for the most financially
rigorous it has been something that the
you have looked down on because you
don't understand what's actually
happening which is I think what
Blackrock has done well let's speak
about Blackrock specifically is it's
actually built a brand and if you
actually understand what's happening in
technology you will realize very quickly
that brand is the only thing left and so
I think that it's given the organization
permission to create other services if
they actually understand the problem is
companies in financial service like
every other company and Chase is a big
client of ours in the US and we do some
work with RBS here I mean it's just it's
just so obvious you can't hold on to
things that are high margin when you
already see the alternative in your face
for the consumer and that's the
vulnerability
I think everybody's doing the same thing
you know - including Blackrock I think
that there is a tone-deaf
nature to the way we communicate to
consumers that comes from an ivory tower
and is completely predicated on
self-interest and then even worse
creatively sits with five or six people
who love the power of having their
subjective point of view be the king or
queen of the decision who then also are
putting out very safe content and
vanilla content which ends up meaning
nothing to anybody and because they're
scared to lose do anything that would
risk this cushy life they have to be the
person that says the videos nice or not
because this is fire as a woman thank
you very much I love the way you talk
about things you feel like you're very
much into democratizing power and I want
to let go there for a second like just
talk about that for a second is you know
you talk about that entire moment like
the fact that you were coming from the
Soviet Union and the hustle and the and
I love that because it goes against you
know we live in a class Society here you
know where so things are about who your
grandfather were and you
wasn't could you you don't you know
what's funny it's not an ideology it's a
practicality I'll be very honest with
you I have a funny feeling if I was if I
was born 40 years ago I would be excited
about classism I'm just like I'm not
excited about the democracy of
everything I just know it's happened
it's called the Internet sorry
like it's over do you understand this
has just started like everything if
you're on defense to what's been
happening right from a classism or I've
put my retail if you have 8,000 leases
and the and it's not everybody talks
about retail is dead TP is dead and then
everybody will counter with like yeah
it's so dead that it's still doing 80
percent of the retail they don't
understand when you go from doing a
hundred percent of the retail to 80
percent the retail when you run an
actual P&L all it needs to do is go to
79 percent for the whole thing to break
because your leases then can't support
like your cogs break when you can't get
out of your lease but your foot traffic
goes down by one percent you're out of
business I I'm I think because of the
way I communicate and because of like my
jersey 'no sand my immigrant Ness I
don't think people pay attention to what
I'm talking
I think they downsize the complete and
utter understanding I have for
psychology and business and I love that
I love you know I will for I probably
manifest and force being underestimated
because it's an advantage ask me why I'm
willing to be self promotional but you
know very little about vaynermedia
that's cuz I'm smart
cuz I didn't want anybody to know
anything about vaynermedia cuz it's way
more dangerous than the incumbents
realize and the more I can make them
think that I'm a charlatan the more time
I have to [ __ ] destroy them
let's go to the next question Gary yes
hi hi
big fan thank good I think you're
probably one of the best content
marketers out there just because you're
so damn efficient Thanks podcast which
you used to create a book which has an
essay as a name wonderful in askgaryvee
hashtag ask a TV talked a lot about
clouds and dirt yes I think clouds is
thinking big but I think dirt is the
work which you also talked a lot about
right I'm really curious if you could
just give me an example of what what
would you consider to be the work and
what is the right word how can people
differentiate between just monotony and
doing the right work that's a great
question I you know let me give you a
clouds and dirt thing I decide that
voice is the next frontier the dirt is I
do a podcast we build an Alexis scale I
spend tons of time watching how people
react to other Alexis I fly to Seattle
for two hours just to meet the tech
stars Alexa team on my dime which is
rare these days and fly back you know
I'm putting I follow up my macro thesis
with micro work to close the gaps
because what I realized over the last 20
years is you know many people in here
have opinions about things based on
headline reading not practitioner ship I
don't want that vulnerability I don't
like when I hang out with very smart
people and then I realized they have no
idea what they're talking about in the
area that I understand I grew this about
wine growing up in the wine business I
became deeply educated and all of a
sudden I started meeting fancy
three-star Michelin sommeliers and I
realized actually he or she doesn't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
they're using put you know their brand
their status but their headline it's
become like much bravado I stay in my
lane there's a ton of stuff of how
wealth that I could never talk about
anywhere close to the level that the
people in this room understand right so
I stay in my lane I the right work is
very subjective for example all my fancy
friends think me community managing and
replying to everybody on Instagram is
the stupidest use of my two hours I
think it's the reason I'm the best
sumer researcher in the world who's
right who's wrong I don't know it all
plays out in the end
I think what we need to do is not judge
ourselves overly in small pockets I
think people start dwelling when they
look back and say oh the last three
months I wasn't doing smart work it's
three months out of a hundred years so I
think judgment on oneself is an
important conversation around this
otherwise you start dwelling on
inefficient work it's good to be
thoughtful but I think people get caught
up and like is this smart you know I
mentioned it earlier I don't know I'm a
big fan of offense I use this analogy
last night in proper football terms I
want my team to win nine to seven which
is an unusual score when I talk about in
the u.s. I talk about 157 to 142 in
basketball that's who I am and I think
that is a very good model because what
you realize is that means you don't
respect defense and when you don't
respect defense it's actually another
way to say hey everybody who's a CFO
centric company in the world and let me
save you time that's all of them like
CEO and CFO dynamics are funny I was
like wait a minute this is only the last
three years from him like wait a minute
CEOs don't run companies CFO's run
companies I'm like that's stupid so yep
she's in a backup hi what's your name
move to the next verse Siri all these
type of technologies and with the
backlash that's happened in terms of
privacy terms where do you think the
opportunities are because do you think
this is just a blip where everyone 70
thinks oh my this thing listening on all
of my private conversations or our
people on mass going to say actually I
don't really care if companies number
two and see think people won't care I
know people don't care and over TV will
continue because I think especially in
terms of younger demographics people
have correct yeah I think I think it go
I think I've I actually think it goes
way further than that I actually think
the greatest thing in the world would be
for all of you to realize there's no
privacy he's super naive let's play it
out no let's play it out let's play it
out we've been very aware like no no
Snowden has been around me I would argue
you would argue and I think you'd agree
with me that over the last 24 to 36
months this has become a much bigger
thing when do people most back most act
when it first becomes aware people most
act when something first becomes aware
and we're not acting at all like like if
you look at this is not my opinion this
is macro data
everyone's like unsubscribed from
Facebook really like look look at all
the data like really Alexis like with
all the mainstream media that gets
clicks for the propaganda that Alexis
listening to you a lexan Google home are
staggeringly growing we don't here let
me tell you why we will ultimately not
care about privacy because the number
one underrated thing in the universe is
the human being we need to get over our
cynicism in a hundred year period and we
will as things become more transparent
I'm completely bought in that will there
be blips where they'll be places sure
but like I think people really don't
understand human beings I just really
think people don't understand big why do
human beings live in
in dictatorships why do like human
beings live like like the judgment that
we'd opposed like like on people that
live in China or Venezuela or Belarus
like I think people are very naive and
so what I mean by that is there will
always be something else there's always
things in play this is giving us more
power not less of course I do you mean
insurance no I mean insurance what I
mean by that is of course I think that
people can make a lot of money by
selling fear and yes I think a lot of
you will fall for it yeah I think I I
think that that will happen and I think
that it will be a small percentage
because I think subconsciously it sounds
great on paper but it's not the reality
of how it works
for example let's play for a second just
for fun Javan what is so scary about
Google owning your data
let's just play for a second like I
everybody got in such an uproar about
Cambridge analytic on Facebook like talk
to me like what ads are more relevant to
you like like what have you guys been
doing what if credit card companies been
doing what if retail stores been doing
like like you know I think that it's
fear-mongering of the current platforms
and I'm just I'm just really darn
curious what Apple's gonna do to you
with your data let's talk about
cooperation is not democratically
enacted government sorry
yeah no no but I mean that's I have to
react that way because I think that's an
important part and I think that's a you
you're very smart that's exactly where
this needs to go but keep going let me
ask you a question
let me ask question would you rather
platforms with data with the ability to
get information in front of you have the
chance to influence you versus you mean
the way we had it where for old white
dudes influenced everybody well let me
save you time that's what it was it was
Rupert Murdoch and red and all the
people yeah but but no note stop stop
stop stop Jasmine you don't consume
their media that means you would also
not consume the Facebook content that
you think that they have the power we've
have always had choice and we do there's
a laughable conversation that if you
chose not to read something or watch a
certain channel that miraculously they
would penetrate you on Facebook that
just not how it works it's about control
because before why do they might
influence it's not some you're wrong
let's play it out let's let's play it
out there's let's play it out you know I
think there's a naivete of supply and
demand the supply of the four white
dudes filled all the buckets the
supplied the Internet is endless the
reason we have more radical points of
view is the endlessness but I think
there's something that Jasmine I would
over tea would get to the same place I
think we believe in a lot of the same
things I think what would end up
happening after our lovely tea is that
the question that most matters is where
do we hold ourselves accountable let me
just save you time whether it's the four
old white dudes or the new platforms we
need to start looking at ourselves for
accountability we choose we choose and
there's an incredible interest to how
we're being manipulated we've always
been manipulated we're always gonna
continue to be manipulated or we're not
depending on how you're wired so I think
you know there's a lot to that but I
don't I don't think there are smaller or
or the Internet's vaster there's more
information which means there's more
fragmentation we more thought alike now
you are very fine to say you know what I
liked when four people controlled it
because we were all more here and that
might be a very valid argument it's
probably similar to my argument about
why I think China will win it's more
like a business there's some things that
are you know dictatorship there's some
things that are more capitalistic but I
don't I don't think you know that I
think that's the way we have to think
about it like they they had 100 percent
penetration between two points of view
it's why we were all closer
the reason we're expanding but I think
we have to hold ourselves accountable
you have to say Facebook and Google run
on your attention if they feed you
things that you don't want if you're
conservative and you're getting nothing
but liberal stuff outside of the fact
that you want to engage with it or if
you like football but you're getting
basketball
the only asset that Facebook has is your
attention thus they want to give you
what you want what I think we're
struggling with is very simple I think
people think technology
changing us I think it's exposing us I
think we don't want to be held
accountable I think we don't like who we
actually are what do you think what do
you would I want it I want it I want to
give her some time I think it's fair
what do you think and I kind of think of
Star Wars and all the guys in white
suits you know they will just March the
line because that's the way it's going
and it's that the way it's going them
and when you say things like but you
know I the brakes approach oh that was
controlled by the internet will do
wasn't control my yeah well let's talk
there's so many things that yeah but
here's the thing I think we try to talk
about these things in not in one term
not the overall thing like how many
people voted for brexit you know where
does that sit on accountability like
there's so many variables in play here
and once again I think that we are
looking at the current state of media
consumption and content and we're not
having it in a alternative the reason I
bring up the alternatives is those are
the alternatives and then I think
there's no difference between clicking
the channel buying the newspaper that
you decide to buy or the stuff that's
coming in your feed I think the reason
people think there is is because I think
they lack the education on what's
actually happening in those feeds and
why I believe that
sharra Ferger right here and then we're
going to go to the back of the room
clearing hey I'm John Allen I was
looking for a bit of advice for any of
the entrepreneurs in the room it sounds
like you're doing podcast books multiple
investments managing a services business
etcetera etcetera how do you deal with
the context switching between all these
different things is there it sort of an
approach you take or a method that you
used to sort of stay focused and be able
to jump between all these different than
the two hours they spend with consumers
okay how do you keep going through how
to manage that context which I never get
it very simply which is I scratched the
itch that needs it at the moment I think
there's too much upfront planning and
then we get paralyzed by over planning
it how do I handle it I don't think
about it I know what my responsibilities
are
I have plates in the air and I don't
know this plate feels like it's starting
to not spin as well and so I'll spin it
and then and then I try to in parallel
try to pay attention to the plates I'm
like do I even want that plate so you're
trying to be thoughtful while executing
macro micro clouds and dirt and and I
think ultimately Jon I think the biggest
thing that works for me is not over
judging it like I'm not devastated if
that plate falls because guess what I
have 41 plates and like the net of 40
it's back to this net game of 157 it's
nine seven one could argue like your
defense is rubbish I'm like cool I won
got it
you know I think it depends on once you
hold the mic let's play it first of all
there's so many things going on here and
I love this guy I mean I would I would
say here for fifteen hours and talk with
you guys about this because it's super
interesting right like it's our lives
meaning first we have to start with what
information like the I'll answer that
but I just want to like we're all here
we're clearly got momentum in this
conversation like what information that
you like root beer that you're that you
that this is where you shop this is how
much you spend your Social Security
number like where are we going here I
again I think that we're reading
headlines we need to have this
conversation what information Google has
more than Facebook financial services
have more I'm Way more scared that Chase
has my social security number Facebook
doesn't like so that's number one number
two I would recommend them being
accountable let me tell you what I let
me tell you the scariest year of my life
in like this topic from October 2001 to
October 2002 I went to Al Jazeera's
website a lot and even back then I was
like hmm I have a funny feeling the FBI
knows I'm doing this right even back
then you know I don't know like again
let's talk this out false information so
ok you read an article in Facebook which
by the way you can read in the Sun as
well with like this notion that human
journalists that work of these companies
are the truth like this is a very
important conversation so anyway back to
your question what about a policy about
a person that's running for office about
the information about the environment I
don't know what should you do you should
do what all thoughtful people do which
is you should be open to a lot of pieces
of information versus what actually is
happening in this wave of emotion which
is maybe you're just actually reading
something you want to be reading and
it's reinforcing what you want to
believe and that is what we need to
unpack you know I don't know I mean like
I you know there's an important thing
here this notion that these that these
Russians are getting in and giving you
an article about this
point of view it's just it's a very
interesting headline and and I and I
love I love even talking about this
because I love trying to map what people
are thinking I love when people tell me
I'm naive right I really love that
because I would argue we have to have a
conversation about the human spirit and
I want you know listen I want people to
understand how this actually works the
last 70 years that were built on more
closed media produced the Nazis produced
all these things they produced them my
friends you have to understand how it
actually works right I was born in the
Soviet Union my mom wrote a book report
pre-internet my mom wrote a book report
that Fidel Castro was the bravest man in
the world that he was in the face of
this awful place called America in this
small little island was one man who is
so brave and so special and his name's
Fidel Castro and he's the best is that
right is that wrong this is a more
complicated what do I think people
should do I think they should be
thoughtful and educate themselves from
different points of view after 9/11 I
went on al-jazeera every day because I
wanted to hear what they had to say
because I was curious on the point of
view you know why is Russia gaining
momentum because they're using the
Internet but also Russia won the network
channel that people are thrilled to put
on their cable service providers because
they get a [ __ ] Vig on the $3.00 per
subscription but it's also allowing
people to hear a different point of view
like different points of view they come
in all media forms not just the Internet
comes in print and radio and television
it's always been the same here's one
difference there's scale on the Internet
which is why you'll get extreme points
of view
you'll get fragmented point it and we're
gonna have to go through this
let's do do one more question and we're
going to moving to over here a quick
question you talked about blockchain and
the fact of financial services need to
give it more focus what do you think is
the next vertical next industry that's
going to be really distracted by blow
time I'm not sure I even think
blockchain itself is still murky for me
but here's what I know that a lot of
people aren't educated enough about
blockchain and understand like new block
chains will be built ultimately here's
what I know when when you get into a
place of peer-to-peer I'm a big believer
that actually happening here with
technology is it's making us go all the
way back because that's how life works
with technology right like look what
voice is gonna do it's gonna make us go
back to like a radio environment that we
thought we left in the 40s it's really
fun to watch like all this podcast
consumption well this is what our
great-grandparents did around a big box
we're just moving around with it it's
super fun to watch this I think that
blockchain has the potential to take us
back to the early villages where it was
really based on you know you're gonna be
trading on your reputation and currency
there's going to be a place that nobody
in the middle has to make a Vig between
me selling your home because the lease
transaction is gonna happen on the
blockchain I mean it's really
fascinating stuff financial service
companies make a lot of money to be in
the middle that middle is on call
blockchain to me is even a scarier thing
than the internet you know I love how
everybody's like our mortgage businesses
are getting disrupted by these internet
mortgage people right and I'm like wait
to see what the blockchain is gonna do
to you you know so I don't know but I
know this it's going to be very
comfortable for you and I you and I when
the blockchain is accepted for you and I
to make any transaction and the fact
that none of the dollars have to go to
anybody else is going to be attractive
to you and I and that is a real
technology and when you think about what
financial services do that really
creates a wrinkle to a lot of the margin
because it's trust it's just trust a
couple quick questions for your
rapid-fire cuz the countdown clock is
long
who is the Gary V for Gary Vee like
who's the person that you follow up
nobody my mom she is not as much make
sure you call her this evening
oh well um what's your theme song the
eye of the tiger not surprising
most underestimated country that we're
not talking about huh that's a good
question
uh that's interesting um a couple things
I'll just give you some things that came
to mind I'm super interested in Africa
as a whole Ghana specifically it's got
my attention
hmm and that's what I'll stick with
nothing comes to super mine the health
of my family and myself only that it's
just doesn't feel controllable
everything else feels as you can tell
controllable to me um you know it's
funny I don't think and this was a
couple other answers I don't think I
that you know it's so funny I'm a
contradiction and make them a little bit
I so value time and then I don't value
time and I never think about that I
think I make the best choices I can and
I let the chips fall where they may
um you know not much I mean you know I
think anybody who's truly happy would be
crazy to do anything over again because
then some other Domino would have hit
some other Domino this is what I hate
when people struggle with choices you're
not gonna know the alternative and you
know and so you know we do everything
exactly say
and final piece of advice for the room
depart look I think the biggest thing I
could say is we are so lucky to be
living through this time of change you
know this is a binary thing you either
see this from an optimistic point of
view or a pessimistic point of view I
just know I know and I watch it in every
angle high-low left-right entitlement
coming from nothing this is the great
opportunity there's such a land grab of
opportunity and happiness
it's about getting educated in the
details and having a binary point of
view of like either you're on or you're
off and and I I don't want people to be
regretful of how special this time was I
understand and I'm very empathetic to
lots of the points of views we talked
about here both socially obviously
business-wise as well this is an
enormous opportunity and I really hope
you you look at it through that lens
give me give me 30 days of pure optimism
in offense and look at all these things
you might be you might be interested in
what you find thank you
[Applause]
[Music]